welcome to Hannity we begin tonight a
Fox News Alert big breaking positive
developments to share surrounding the
deep state this is very detailed pay
close attention I've got two unpeel the
layers of this onion first I have to
admit the McCabe news on the declination
for prosecution is frustrating
especially when the IG had identified
four separate incidents of lack of
candor that means lying seems as I said
last night only conservatives they seem
to get punished for that in today's
America now what we know is this is the
single biggest abuse of power
scandal corruption scandal in modern
American history and it is playing out
before our very eyes we now see that the
corruption at the highest levels of
government what we've been talking about
unequal justice a lack of equal
application of our laws equal justice
under the law a two-tier justice system
operated by a group of again the 1%
lawless vindictive evil government
officials all of this is on the line in
this country and it matters how it turns
out but we have reason tonight that your
hearts not be troubled why because big
major consequential developments clearly
are on the horizon now so far we have
been completely vindicated on everything
we have reported to you the media Mob
three long years of Lies and conspiracy
theories and hoaxes and smears and
slander and besmirched men and
everything else in between
propaganda tonight at this hour there
are still career unelected bureaucrats
who hate president Trump hate that you
elected him and are on what is an
unyielding mission to continue to
destroy anyone and everyone who supports
him and the events unfolding this week
represent the perfect example of
everything we have been telling you for
three years on this show
Robert Muller's Trump hating minions
recommended first-time offender Rogers
don't get nine years in prison nine
years for a processed crime what over a
few overblown lies nonviolent processed
crime two glowing four counts of lying
to Congress well they lie every
Adam Schiff lives that almost every word
that comes out of his mouth
on the other side breaking today we
learned Andrew McCabe will face no
charges no trial no nothing McCabe lied
over and over again and we prove that it
was fired by the DOJ for his lying in
the Department's inspector general
recommended him for federal prosecution
writing quote McCabe lack candor on
multiple occasions three of those
occasions involved this testimony under
oath and that's not all McCabe even
admitted he lied to the FBI but Andrew
McCabe is facing no charges whatsoever
and get this look at your screen because
breaking moments ago fellow deep state
hack Lisa Paige is celebrating she
posted that picture on Twitter holding a
glass of wine caption cheers Andy and
keep in mind the same classless
individual she was forced to resign from
the FBI and disgrace after exchanging
dozens and dozens of nasty text messages
about Donald Trump with the pure ugly
political bias with our best friend
Peter struck you know the guy that said
oh I can smell them from here the smelly
Trump supporting Walmart shoppers what a
great pair they are apparently if you're
a trump hating bureaucrat or a Democrat
oh you can perjure yourself or lie to
the FBI with zero consequences or can
you come to think of it look at your
screen if Colby or Hillary Clinton or
quid pro quo gel or any prominent
Democrat or deep state official seems at
this hour but it's about to change I
think you can commit a whole host of
potential crimes and not even face an
indictment but if you're Roger stone a
Paul Manafort by the way we're not
taking a high-ranking government
official and then you have no power
whatsoever but if you're stolen and you
lie to Congress they want to put you
away for Oh nine years by the way the
median time spent in prison for rape is
four years in two months
murder just a little over 13 years yeah
that's real but breaking tonight this
could all be changing very soon we are
now beginning to see something very
large unfold moments ago Roger stones
attorneys have filed a motion for a new
trial that is a major development that
should be granted
and by the way it should be the
beginning of Stone's ultimate
vindication we have more good news
McCabe dismissal is frankly when you
really look at it it's a declination
prosecute on one specific issue here's
my read between that and general Flynn
news today because we know that Barnes
just installed an outside counsel to
look into the general Flynn case so I'm
reading the tea leaves here and my
sources confirming the same sources that
I've been using for you and getting the
story right for three years that the
Attorney General Bill Barr is now
focused on something much bigger much
deeper that will have far ranging
ramifications serious ramifications for
that 1% that abused power that 1%
involved in the corruption those deep
state bureaucrats who abuse their power
because as we speak the dorm bar
criminal probe is underway I've been
told by my sources that in fact it has
gone deep it has gone wide it has gone
far and the evidence they are
accumulating is overwhelming and
incontrovertible that's what my sources
are telling me tonight on this program
we refer to all of this as the
investigation into the investigators now
according to reports this investigation
is scrutinizing the actions now and
we've been wondering when this is gonna
come former CIA director John Brennan
and many other current and former deep
state officials responsible for the
Russia hoax remember the origins of the
Russia hoax that's the heart of the
investigation and now it has expanded
out far and wide Durham has spent weeks
in Italy and Great Britain that would
tell me and indicate to me that the
outsourcing of intelligence gathering
and spying on Americans to circumvent
American law is in play I am told that
this evidence that we already have that
it was about premeditated fraud on a
FISA Court nobody else in the media got
that story right we got it right on this
program the evidence is proven it's a
slam dunk case we already have that and
Barr has already confirmed got to pay
attention that the FISA applications
were fraudulent Barr has already
confirmed that a candidate
Trump his transition team and deep into
the presidency of Donald Trump spying
happened yes he used the word spying
okay now we know about the warnings
multiple warnings that were given to
those when they filed the FISA
applications don't trust Ely as an
agenda
Hillary paid for it and it's not
verified multiple warnings that means
premeditated fraud on the court that
means a huge day of reckoning to me
seems to be on the horizon I may be
wrong I don't think so
it also would mean potential charges for
so many who recklessly abused the FISA
Court or any of this nation's powerful
tools of intelligence we entrust you
with those tools you don't get to turn
them on the American people because you
have a political agenda and a new
development that's not all and we
learned today the bar ordered outside
prosecutors to review the case of
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn thank
God you might remember James Comey
bragging on camera about oh setting
Flynn up and all I sent my guys in there
I'd never do that in the in the Trump
war or Bush administration's or ever get
away with it decorated military hero 33
years they forced him to plead guilty to
one charge lying to investigators but
the investigators actually didn't think
he was lying why did he do it because
they threatened to go after his family
and his kid and he already had to sell
his house because he couldn't pay his
lawyers and their initial reports the
agents wrote that Flynn didn't appear to
be lying
so they made him lie so he could save
his son what father I guess wouldn't do
that good for general Flynn and here's
how I interpret that action I can now
see the general Flynn will be vindicated
I can believe tonight and I have
believed tonight that the Durham bar
probe will deliver a devastating blow to
the deep state which has to happen well
we might as well take our Constitution
and shred it because equal justice under
the law and application of our laws will
be dead but these are clear messages now
being said when Barre stepped in and
stopped the prosecutorial abuse on Roger
stone that was huge that case needs to
be vacated completely as we now know the
jury foreperson had a political agenda
Oh a Democrat an activist Democrat that
it actually even talked about the case
and to date my sources have been right
the entire time so tonight
I can report this I am cautiously
optimistic that real justice will be
done and it seems like the decks of
being cleared looks like a five-alarm
fire happening at the Justice Department
and we should know in short order well
short order meeting a few months what
will happen how this will fall out to
his credit the president as the Attorney
General said yesterday has given the
Attorney General the DOJ Inspector
General the space to conduct what is
important independent investigations is
completely what by the way within the
president's power to order the probe
himself did you know the president is
the chief law enforcement officer in the
country he's number one when the aichi
stepped in to amend the egregious
sentencing of Roger stone he did that on
his own what he did with general Flynn
he did on his own according to a brand
new report from Kimberly Strasser Wall
Street Journal here's what actually
happened quote and her sources have been
impeccable interim US attorney Tim Shea
told the department's leadership he and
other career officials in the office
felt the proposed sentence was excessive
as for the deadline for the filing is
that near the prosecutors on the case
nonetheless threatened to withdraw from
the case unless they got their demands
for the stiffest penalties met mr. Shea
new to the job suffered a moment of
cowardice and submitted to that
ultimatum high-ranking DOJ officials
made to decide these things they decided
to reverse the sentencing way before the
president issued any tweet condemning it
but for the Trump aiding prosecutors
hell-bent on revenge and prosecutorial
zealousness and frankly in my mind
overreach and abuse resigned in a fit of
anger apparently and as stressful points
out they failed to realize that career
civil servants aren't some aristocratic
class entitled to immunity from
supervision their employees the danger
is in political authority but rather an
unelected Mandarin class that believes
itself exempt from democratic
accountability of course Democrats will
never let the truth get in the way of a
good old-fashioned anti Trump witch-hunt
will they congressman Doug Collins of
Georgia now warning that Democrats are
using the stone sentencing for an excuse
now they're talking about another
impeachment push
and you have of course the compromised
corrupt congenital liar and coward areas
Adam Schiff he's foaming at the mouth
already and the only way to stop another
Schumer's shift sham show well there's
only one way that I know in 263 days
you're the ultimate jury you can shock
the world again and if you vote for the
president-elect republican congressmen
and senators they can't do this anymore
this is the most consequential election
frankly in modern history and i'm not
overstating the case we are now as a
nation and frankly the world on the
brink but tonight we have reason to be
hopeful i can't give you a timeline for
the investigation into the investigators
because the wheels of justice move
pathetically slow drives me nuts but i
think it's coming to a head
the DOJ stepping in on stone that is not
a small thing the for hacks leaving the
DOJ that's not a small thing the review
of the Flynn case that's not a small
thing either and the weeks of weeks and
weeks that Durham and Barre have spent
abroad that is sending a real signal
that they want to get to the outsourcing
of spying on Americans and that brings
it right to the front door of John
Brennan what did he know when did he
know it clapper what did he know when
did he know it and what did Obama know
and when did he know it
so I'm putting aside my temporary anger
I'm praying that justice is now near